we wish you a Merry Christmas and a
Happy New Year
all right what's up believe nation
tomorrow is Christmas so we thought we'd
make a special Christmas edition of the
vlog a bunch of guys have been sending
in presents and I haven't opened them
for a while so we're doing a special
Christmas edition of mail time thank you
guys for sending in the gifts Nina wants
to come in and say hi if you want to
send us something for our future mail
time the address is gonna be in the
description below let's get started okay
so we gotta mention the packages here
we're gonna open them up give some you
guys we appreciate it
first one let's do this one because it's
easiest this one is from Tuan from dude
Buddha last time you gave us these these
t-shirts and a hat selfie stick selfie
stick called steve-o oh nice I'll change
the angle so you can go like boom all
right thank you twine go next looks like
a book we always get tons of books we
love the books it's a book don't shoot
the dog but who gave me this
Karen Pryor thank you Karen appreciate
the book this one okay
she loves fence it says no regret no
regret Nina has the nails will open yes
oh what's your why what's your why
Sheila Spence thank you for the love
feel like this is a left-handed mug yeah
great no it's not you
let people see what but when you're
drinking it there's something on the
side I drink right-handed I guess they
can see it but I can't see us I'm gonna
learn to drink left-handed just enough
just to use this money and a nice note
watching the YouTube channel
my word is regrets I don't want any
regrets
I love it when you drink your morning
espresso I hope you're drinking this mug
you think of Sheila's friends the
California Girls was designed what's
your why app for inspiration alright I
love it alright thank you Sheila next
this one going oh nice
I'm Cheryl looks like cookies cookies oh
look at this after hanging goes to bed
that's what I'm showing down on right ha
it's my feast day oh thank you Cheryl's
Santa doesn't eat with his beard so
what's in there ok can I open one I mean
open one
these guys go from the CEO club t-shirts
dare to be different
CEO club this is mine why what's that
millionaire-in-training
in training yeah all right
I love it Thank You CEO club appreciate
this go that it's a book pull tab to
open pull this way it's a cooking book
who's it from who's it from love Kelly
Levesque Thank You Kelly
my name is gonna many cooks with me
thank you coming over that's what recipe
is telling the VEX cookbook for women
Thank You Kelly Kelly learn how to cook
for Chinese wives and eight-year-old
boys for your amazing husband and father
for Chinese women ate your homeboy boy
there we go look at that alright I
appreciate it Kelly Levesque come Derek
there King whoa it's a Raptors hat
I like the Raptors I like Blue Jays more
but I like the Raptors to enjoy all
material security is my wandering Derek
King all right Thank You Derek Cheers
trying to Raptors Hayden hello
I'm opening one here we go it's a book
from Jennifer McClellan
the detox dish Chinese wise and eight
year old boy can cook forever I love it
sour cream guacamole
YUM all right Thank You Jennifer from
sleep and beyond happy birthday oh this
is really old
may your birthday if you need to
remember thank you for the love sleeping
beyond I appreciate it Oh what do you
guys know from Mara Sullivan Mara Sol
Solomon okay I'll put it up what do we
got
it's a book blue oceans shipped beyond
competing blue ocean shipped by W Chan
Kim and Rene mal Borneo trooping steps
to inspire confidence and season of
growth thank you for the love early
weeding the advance copy not for sale
all right Mirko Solomon's okay it's a
book another book it's the same book hey
two copies all right Nina gets three to
coffee
hating-ass through the coffee Hayden the
first rule of fieldwork experience what
buyers experience I feel like he was
moved by that thank you what's in there
that's a huge package michael hyatt your
best year ever your best year ever
five-step plan for to be your most
important book and a notebook the full
focus planner so I gotta write down
three main tasks big task of the day
other tasks morning rituals and some
quotes at the top all right I just went
out and bought a journal like last week
it could have used this all right I like
this wet don't just write
write down your motivations you lose
your way if you lose your why what's
your why there are these quotes on these
cards I don't know if therefore they
almost look like coasters thank you for
the love Michael Hyatt timer trick
DeLong enterprises for Dylan Dylan Dylan
oh it's a goal get unstuck and move
towards your dreams boom go thank you so
much for responding my Instagram message
I love it
the bookish woman's experience alright I
like it thank you for the love thank you
for the love from Cora Western it in the
Netherlands Thank You Cora look inside
looks like there's nothing for is cheesy
game oh dear eminent Nina
woo I made keyrings for you because of
the positive energy of your work and
YouTube by one word is love
alright thank you kindly I like that
let's look at art earrings oh ho chains
I'm getting the red one Nina gets the
pink one okay thank you for the love
Cora really milking this one three
copies of this one three copies of blue
ocean ship all right maybe I'll have to
give them away to a competition sean
Fitzpatrick oh my god
thank you look at that big break thank
you thank you for doing what you're
doing I'm being an inspiration to me
love Thank You China
what's your Shona we're round repeal but
we're not an orange
Snickers look at that look at these
belief plane stickers that's pretty cool
Thank You Shauna absolute property of
Evan Carmichael believe nation I like
that Thank You Shauna I love that a
thank you card from teri and Christine
wailing wailing dog thank you for the
beautiful something copy of your one
word Oh advance maybe autograph
autographed copy of your one word
I'm beginning to read it and will soon
write my review I love your create a
bookmark well done Thank You Terry
I love it it's a bug let's return it was
returned to Cypress oh no we spent money
sending this a cypress and it was
unclaimed a copy of probably hear one
word probably a cough rise winner Daniel
and Alex write to me from Cyprus your
book my return I want to get it to you
know what right no I'm sure it's from
the hood Lily and the octopus does that
Lily mom Lily MA your one word coach
this is from Stephen Rowley electronic
Comfort the first page doesn't go all
the way
all right it's a nice book Thank You
Lily and the octopus we'll check it out
nice
Louise what we got Lois two bucks from
louis Oh
TD jakes TD jakes his new books or you
had him on the channel the interview and
talk about it nice this is his book for
Entrepreneurship so he's got a lot of
books on on mostly spirituality but this
is his first I think I'm
entrepreneurship well thank you Bishop
James hello and clothes are two copies
of soar enjoy TV Jake's ministries
arrived Oh
remove simple program calm I love it
let's see whether we go what does it say
trust the process
thank you kindly simple play grammar out
Michael Patrick oh my god
attention he said - he said three
attention Evon attention evan caracal
team attention lily mom okay well Lily
mommy can't do every Chronicle team
Sanka
Sandra Sanchez doesn't send us out here
Sandra this one's for you from Michael
Patrick thank you there we go just want
to pass along a note of thanks for
reaching that to me and being so helpful
and sending up my review of Evans one
word I'm grateful for the opportunity
yeah Michael Patrick still feel 21
that's his website this one is me just
wanted to extend some thanks for having
your team members being in touch with me
and working with me I love it man
Michael Patrick he does a hangout he
doesn't YouTube hang out with Lily once
a week on her on this channel thank you
Michael
I'll give this one to Lily all right but
Jeff Davis the power of authentic
leadership with Jeff Davis some books to
read I'd like to feel let's do this this
fragile handle of care from Nova Scotia
doesn't say you go alright Nova Scotia
thank you for the love gentle look at
this artwork salt right made in the
Maritimes believe believe even believe
it's the jose bautista backflip i think
this one i don't know who did that who
did this is it toronto what's it what's
it looks like toronto right that's the
best of don valley river
i think if you look closely it's toronto
i want to know who that is
that's Jose Bautista for sure alright we
never figure what to do
I like it ash thankfully right t-bone
huh you liked it huh yeah don't lick my
beer hey oh oh Santa
thank you guys for the kisses thank you
guys hear the Christmas love and all the
presents if you want to send me
something open up on camera there's an
address in the description said to the
CVS and you might be on the next mail
time have an amazing Christmas from me
from Nina from Hayden Hayden someone
from Timo we love you we appreciate you
the Humber fantastic New Year's to love
though will make another meeting for New
Year's
that's it much love